see and loud humming allah assalamu
alaikum peace be with you
I may be your host you're watching the
day show thank you for tuning in today
on this week's show we have a special
young lady who was out there on MTV she
was a superstar pop sensation I mean
drew crowds from all over it by the tens
of thousands and was at the top of the
music change she was performing with
people such as Justin Bieber was a jay
Park and all of these other pop culture
music icons but something was missing it
was missing and Fame couldn't fill that
void money status she had all that but
something else did and we're gonna be
talking to her miss Nina why she left
that lifestyle that people are running
towards towards this lifestyle the
lifestyle that brings you peace
prosperity contentment in this life
paradise to the next we're gonna hear
her story coming up next miss Nina don't
go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with us on the Deen show miss Nina
assalamu alaikum peace be with you
and how are you doing sister Nina come
I'll hum do I'm doing very well thank
you very much and thank you so much for
being with us here on the Deen show oh
it is such an honor thank you so much
for having me here
and Allah you know for reaching out and
inshallah my story and inshallah my
words will be able to to be a benefit to
other people and hopefully he could help
other people as well so she'll tell us
we're over here in the United States has
the Deen show reached your part of the
world you know what it has I actually
tweeted about this I think it was last
week and we have a Muslim Channel
Islamic channel here called TV al Hydra
and when I switched it on immediately it
was it was the Dean show and I was like
how do you love amazing and so I tweeted
about it and I think a week after I
received an email from the Deen show so
mashaallah I I'm very happy that you
know this your show has been going on it
has honestly speaking before I even put
the hijab on I've been I was watching a
show and I was doing a lot of research
about Islam and you know looking for my
way in my path towards Islam and
hamdulillah it has been a really good
journey and thank you for having the
show you know it's it's such it's such
an amazing show and I hope that more
people get to watch it and see it and
know about it thank you so much Justin
inna sister Nina tell us people are
excited they want to know the not yet
Muslims the Muslims they want to know
how
what was the turning point in your life
now the turning point that had you
really start to research reflect and get
you to where you are today please talk
to us about this well you know I in in
my life in my past so um I kind of call
it past life because um I I would call
myself a revert you know I was born a
Muslim but I didn't really practice much
when I was young and I think through
through the years you know I as you know
I was an artist I was a pop artist I was
a rapper I did a lot of things on stage
and and all that so anyway that's the
past life and what really led me towards
Islam and towards looking for knowledge
really was you know I felt like I had
something that was missing inside of me
you know I was searching and reaching
for goals of the dunya and I didn't
realize that it was Li just leading me
to nowhere and I think you know my
brother passed away a few years ago and
that was probably one of the turning
points that I had in my life which kind
of pushed me towards really
understanding more about my Deen and
that actually pushed me to actually
start praying sulla um a few times a day
once a day first I started once a day
then after that a hamdulillah you know I
met my husband and he prays five times a
day you know he's a good Muslim
alhamdulillah and he taught me to pray
five times a day and he taught me to
slowly try to read the Quran and then
from there you know I my mom and dad I
humbly another resupport of me um they
take me to Umrah and after going for
Umrah to makkah and to to medina it
really you know really opened my heart
and my eyes and and just myself to to to
you know really wanting to become a
better Muslim so Hajj was really the
attorney the biggest the other biggest
turning point in my life where I decided
that I wanted to hunt percent submit
myself to
Ossipon wa ta'ala and to change my life
completely because I'm 33 years old
right now and you know I've lived a
pretty much most of my life living for
this dunya and now it's all about trying
to find a way where I can actually build
a beautiful beautiful eternal life in
Jena shala so you know seeking for
knowledge alhamdulillah you know
Malaysia is such an amazing country like
we're basically a Muslim country but we
do respect other religions as well we
have Christianity we have Buddhism we
have Hinduism I know that hamdullah we
live here in peace but I'm so happy that
our government does support a lot of
classes and Islamic Islamic classes I go
on we have Islamic universities here as
well hamdulillah so this past actually
has only been about five to six months
since I've done my Hajj and and that was
the time I decided to keep on my hijab
these past six months have been amazing
hamdullah I've been able to actually go
out and meet not same meet but actually
go out and listen to a lot of amazing
scholars that have come to Malaysia like
multi-bank
newman ali khan shaykhun all shakes and
Sheikh Walid and humbly Allah you know
it's may Allah grant them the highest
levels of done and for everybody that
teaches our Deen the right way of the
Sunna and from the Quran and from Sahaba
it's just it's just you know seeking for
knowledge for me is I'm I'm a student of
knowledge now so so that's my goal in
life inshallah so yeah you know tell us
you mentioned your brother who had
passed away tell us a little bit about
him please um my brother that passed
away well he passed away when he was in
his 40s yeah he was a special child he
was born with a hole in the heart and
you know when he passed away he had he
met he was married he has one child and
she's she's she's 16 right now she's
doing so well in school hamdullah
her mother's such a such a beautiful
woman to such a good Muslim was Nima as
well and my brother died basically
because of that condition and infected
all of his other organs in his body and
so you know inshallah you know um I hope
to see him in Jannah my property
inshallah you know if you can think back
to when you found out your brother had
died and that moment what it felt like
because I know for myself and many
people the turning point was when
someone close to him died and you really
start to really reflect ponder and think
about that moment of death that you'll
be away from all your loved ones your
loved ones will be away from you you're
in the grave the money can't save you
nothing all the wealth you've amassed
that stays behind you can't take it with
you and the reality kicks in death I'm
really gonna die so share with us that
experience when your you had your
brother it was very close to you when he
passed what was that like so we can
attain some benefit from that okay
inshallah um well you know I was I was
close to my brother and I never thought
that it you know at the time nobody that
was close to me ever passed away I had
no idea what it felt like to lose
somebody that I loved and when I got the
phone call um I knew that he wasn't
really doing well but when I got the
phone call my mom told me that he's gone
he's passed away I was like what I
couldn't believe it I thought I thought
I was dreaming and you know to have
somebody leave you just so I don't know
I was I was heartbroken I I was lost I I
didn't know really what to do what to
think and then I thought to myself like
you know where is my brother now where
did he go
you know is he in is he in heaven is he
is he in his grave at the time I I don't
really know much about Islam so um you
know we you know we we stayed our
prayers we you know we clean them as as
we do and then in there
him and said all the prayers and
everything and then you know that that
at that point I I look took a look at my
life and I really kind of tried to see
you know you know honestly I knew at the
time that I took my life for granted
I took the people around me for granted
my family especially my parents and my
brother who left me and I didn't even
have time to to even to even talk to him
as much as I wanted to and so you know
ah yeah you know I I believe that if all
I'll take something away from you that
you love he's he's really you know he he
all loves us because he's testing us and
so you know that was unfortunately big
you know it was my push towards the Dean
unfortunately you know my brother had to
go but you know inshallah he'll see him
in Jena again but that's the thing the
thing about death is I actually asked
myself this question a couple of months
back when I went for this course called
heart therapy and you know the there was
a question that was that was asked are
you ready to die if you died tomorrow
what would you do this this next 24
hours and would you be ready to meet
allah subhana wa ta'ala and you know if
I asked my question back then um of
course not you know who's ready to die I
mean who wants to die but look this
question is so important like you were
saying you know it's it's it reminds us
of of reality and it reminds us that yes
there is gonna be a heaven and a hell
and it also reminds us that we need to
you know start looking hard at our lives
and seeing whether we're doing the right
things that we need to do to be able to
get to Jannah and at the same time to
face all lost upon what Saul on the day
of ashura
because I know that my brother is in the
grave right now
and I pray to Allah that he he protects
him in the grave from any torture or
torment and he shot
Oh have mercy on his soul and how we all
have mercy on all of our souls I mean
that's right may the Creator times the
earth have mercy on your brother I have
mercy on all those who strive to please
their Creator before they meet their
Creator
I mean you guide us all to the truth the
way that's pleasing to him now tell us
also you mentioned that you had started
praying once one time of day twice three
times finally you got up to five times a
day then you started wearing the hijab
tell us how you made this wonderful
progress yes that was that was pretty
much the way that I kind of found my way
towards you know learning about it more
and and understanding about it more and
believing in it more in actual fact I
you know praying praying once a day was
for me at the beginning was was kind of
hard but I'm Lila because my husband
helped me out so much with this
alhamdulillah I you know from once twice
three times a day you know
coming back from Hajj alhamdulillah I
pray five times a day every day and I
think Salah being you know praying is
one of the most fundamental things is
the most important thing to to pull to
actually pull ourselves towards Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala I feel that every time
that we pray we are actually calling
Allah and we're connecting with him in
in such a direct way and and that is our
source to allah subhana wa ta'ala
outdoors our our wishes is that's the
time when we you know really connect to
them so I believe that anyone who who
starts praying inshaallah they will get
to to know more about islam and to go
deeper and want to go deeper and know
about the knowledge and the Deen and so
yes
you know I a hamdulillah for for Salah
and and yeah
my next question I have sister Dina is
the Hajj we know that Islam submission
to the will of the Creator not the
creation based on five pillars one that
you testified there is nothing worthy of
worship except the create tour
not the creation i'm muhammad peace be
upon him is the last and final messenger
and that would include jesus moses and
all the preceding messenger pray five
times a day
give the poor do the charity there's a
cat faster than every month of ramadan
and the hajj
let's get into the hajj when you went to
hajj you mentioned that this was the
turning point in your life this is where
you wanted to really take this for real
tell us about this okay well before I
went to Hajj you know the last three or
four five years of my life before Hajj I
was a solo artist and I had a couple of
albums out you know I did a few songs
with with a few artists from around the
world and all that and so when my mom
asked me to go to Hajj the first time a
few years ago I was like mom so I'm not
ready yet
because I have have you know I was so
involved in music in the dunya and all
that so I didn't really think about it
too much but think about a year and a
half ago after I returned from Umrah
with my family she asked me again and
then I was like I thought about it and
then I said yes you know I I don't know
how but I think Allah opened myself up
to towards honey led towards becoming
you know to us during the Hajj and and I
knew that doing the Hajj is not like
it's it's not you know it's not for fun
you know I I know I've heard of or I've
seen some people go for Hajj they come
back and not changed and what we wish
for when we go for hajj is a [ __ ] that
is my bro that is accepted by Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala so you know I prepared
myself I went for my Quran classes I
went for Islamic classes and just trying
to prepare myself mentally physically
emotionally to to really try to make
sure that when I get there is all about
ebody is all about about you know
worshiping allah subhana wa ta'ala and
learning even more and masha'Allah when
I was there for Hajj last year in
October 2013 it was oh my goodness I
don't know how to explain you know how
to explain it words
especially on the day of I think it's
called Wilco our fight is one day where
all the Angels come down to earth and
whoever is making Dora at that time
after the horror and to Margaret
insha'Allah the angels will carry you
Dora's up into heaven and mashallah and
I could see everywhere everybody wearing
Ihram and it was such a humbling
experience just to to be a part of this
Ummah you know and to see that you know
everybody is making power but and
repenting and asking for forgiveness and
it was you know it was so moving and
humbly I'm so happy that Allah had
invited myself and I went my husband and
my mom as well and so you know hamdullah
he brought us there and you know when I
was in Makkah I you know I was it's
funny because I was watching um there
was one there's one episode where he had
new Miley Han and the show and he was
talking about some I think a sister she
was confused about the hijab so I was
watching that and I was watching a few
other shows as well and then I was
thinking I said you know what this is it
I if I if I wonder if I'm going to do
this right I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
do it the right way which is you know as
a Muslim I should keep the hijab on and
and if I didn't I don't know if I maybe
if I didn't go for higher to maybe I
wouldn't be on right now but humbly that
it still is and inshallah for forever so
I would recommend anybody who has the
chance to go for Hajj you know instead
of taking a holiday going to you know
the Bahamas are going to you know
anywhere in the world why don't you save
your money and and go for Hajj because
it's life-changing
it is so life-changing it's so it is so
amazing it's I can't even really explain
it you know it's the best time of my
life
mashallah you know and to be there with
my husband at the same time it was I
think our best day ever
mashallah is really exciting this new
store
tell us how do you deal with a lot of
the misinformation the false stereotypes
that are out there about Islam and
Muslims the false stereotypes um okay
well you know I know that Allah like
around the world everybody believes or
thinks that Islam has got to do with you
know terrorism you know is uh is is not
a religion of peace is oppressive
against women you know unfortunately
these are probably housed a lot of
people view Islam who don't really know
about it so you know in Malaysia here in
our country it's not so bad because most
people understand almost well most
people here are Muslim Anila but there
still are misconceptions for example in
terms of the hijab just recently that
was will heat up day and a lot of
sisters here in Malaysia are really
really supportive world hijab day
because sometimes even in in in our
Muslim country we do find a little bit
of discrimination against the hijab as
well you know not many job offers for
example like being an air stewardess or
or working in certain companies they
will not hire you because you read a
hijab so that's one kind of
discrimination that we face here in
Malaysia but you know around the world I
you know I really hope that those people
who just kind of point fingers and say
we're like this or like that inshallah
you know Allah guide them to to find out
more about the truth about our beautiful
beautiful religion it's not about you
know oppression it's not about war it's
about peace it's about love it's balance
you know it's our it's our guidelines
you know it's our guidance and yeah
masha'Allah
tell us what advice do you have now for
many young women old women even men who
are struggling with a lot of the same
issues you were struggling with have an
emptiness in the heart
you don't have peace contentment and
instead of praying five times a day you
call your boyfriend or girlfriend five
times a day and going crazy for the
Justin Bieber and the likes and really
not knowing that you need to change but
really not taking the matter serious and
working more to please the creation
instead of working to please the Creator
what advice do you have for people
struggling with this talk to a sister
please well my advice for all my sisters
you know who are struggling right now to
to make a change to look into your you
know your hearts look into your hearts
to make the change you know I I believe
that you know in the beginning you may
be scared you know I was scared in the
beginning as well I was I was fearful
about you know how how my life could
change how it could be but you know you
know instead of going uh instead of
trying to impress everybody about the
way you look instead of trying to to
idolize you know you know artists like
as if they are gods you know try to look
into your heart and try to see what's
missing and that missing link is is
allah subhana wa ta'ala you know take
that first step you know it could be the
smallest step for example like if your
if your sister that likes to wear you
know miniskirts and cigarettes you know
maybe the next thing that you could do
is try to wear something that covers
your legs and your arms and in your body
you know then after that you know
insha'Allah you know maybe you can can
start you know contemplating your life
sit down for like an hour and think
about your life like where are you now
you know what what is this life about
who created who created this world this
beautiful world this universe who
created the heavens who created a heart
you know it's almost wonder what's our
life and if you if you can try to
connect with that Chawla he will he will
allow you to start praying once a day
twice a day you know and you will see
yourself changing a little bit here and
there you know and another another piece
of advice I like to give her my sisters
is you know it's it's not it's not you
know honestly the beauty real beauty
comes from inside and I think it's the
beauty of modesty as well you know it's
the way you bring yourself and and how
you would carry yourself as as a Muslim
woman so you know don't be scared about
it because you know you're not that's so
there's a lot of people out there who
are struggling and the fact that that
that sisters are actually struggling
Allah loves you Allah loves you more
because you're struggling even more and
insha'Allah you will you'll make that
step you'll take that step to to to to
being a better person to being a better
Muslim you know I you know it's not it's
not an easy thing you know every day
it's a struggle but remember Allah is
always listening to us even though you
know even though you don't know he's not
listening he is listening to you and
what's in your heart and if your
intention really truly is to change he
will help you change you just have to
you just have to reach out to him oh
Allah Masha Allah
tell us how important was a sister for
your development having good company
around you good friends talk to us about
this mm-hmm you know I'm learning from
my teachers they tell me that your
company and your friends are what make
you you know so you go out and you hang
out with people who are who have you
know who have bad influence then you're
probably going to end up like them it
but if you hang out with people who are
good you know who are pious who are
righteous who are truthful and honest
and and good cat with good character
inshallah you will also become like that
so you know who you hang out with are so
important just as important as your
family so I would definitely suggest you
know sisters to make sure you hang up
and you make friends with the right
people and but then again don't forget
about your friends who are who are with
you or who
you know what I mean like who don't
forget about the friends who you think
you feel that you can pull you know to
the other side just because your friend
is not a good character doesn't mean
that your friend might not be in the
future so you know hopefully with a
sister's change you know your friends
will also you know tag along or come
along but friends are so important I
I've noticed since my change as well you
know I've been I've been a lot you see
selectively but somehow or other like I
find myself surrounded by people that I
want to be surrounded with you know with
with with sisters who are on the same
pages mean we're going out you know
looking for Islamic knowledge you know
and we you know we meet each other for
the sake for allah subhana wa ta'ala to
learn more and then you know I'm still
friends with my other girlfriends who
I've been friends with since I was a kid
and they're not wearing hijab yet but
inshallah they will be soon you know
since everybody around our circle is so
it's all about influence good influence
and and friends are that yeah sister
tell us before we come to an end about
how you feel now as opposed to how you
felt back then when you were living a
life of just chasing your desires not
living a life that was pleasing to your
Creator and many people are doing that
now and they don't have that peace and
we know that people such as Justin
Beaver you know on xanax
drugs alcohol their lives are upside
down but they have money they have Fame
they're not happy so you had all of that
but now you gave it up tell us about the
feeling that you have now that price is
feeling that people they would spend all
the money in their bank account to have
but you got it for free tell us about
this okay well you know back then uh I
was I was searching for happiness
the wrong places I was searching for
happiness through my friends I was
searching for happiness through through
the career that I was pursuing in music
in in performing I was searching for
happiness and just all there all of the
wrong places and and you know it really
created a feeling of restlessness of
constantly searching for something but
didn't know what and you know feeling
depressed and lost at many many times
and how many are now now that I have
found all those wanna watch other I feel
I feel so not all the time but inshallah
I feel at peace you know I know that
Allah is with me so when I were to Allah
and I also feel I feel love I feel love
has surrounding me now you know as
compared to before where I was trying to
search for love in the wrong places
where you know our first love is allah
subhanho wa taala and at the same time I
feel content you know with my life where
Allah has given me you know before
before this will change I was never
really happy with what I had even though
I had everything in the world you know I
wasn't even I was I was wasn't even sure
where was I was I really wanted um but
you know contentment you know feeling
the e-class eClass meaning I was waiting
English this is your honey she's Sarah P
thank you very much you know sincerity
about the things that I do the decisions
that I make before like I wouldn't even
think and I make a decision and then
I'll end up like end up where I don't
want to be so now you know Allah has
given me taqwa knowing what's right and
what's right what is right and what is
wrong he's he's a hamdullah given me um
I pray for it class as well for
sincerity for the things that we do you
know nowadays when I make decisions
especially with my work
I have to know okay by me doing this is
this going to going to be against a las
penitas wishes is it against the Sunnah
or Quran or you know is it is it
something that that's gonna lead to
something bad so so I've never had this
kind of thought process before you know
and humbly Allah you know it's it's it's
really really trying to find peace and
happiness in life and that peace I
believe comes from praying five times a
day from doing the disease that you need
to do as a Muslim you know pay zero
zakah fasting during Ramadan and going
for Hajj or maybe going to Umrah as well
and also you know building good
character you know making sure that you
are always in check with what's going on
inside of you and making sure that your
connection with allah subhana wa ta'ala
is always there at any given time you
know there are special times I read in
the book that that when you make dua
that all I will listen to you and
inshallah will accept it so you know you
can make draw at any time you're driving
in the car if you're home you know the
Allah has everywhere so that connection
with Allah and is what gives me peace if
I if I stopped my that connection I know
that I would be I wouldn't be I wouldn't
be around I you know I'd be left behind
so you know the key is to have that
connection and to contemplate about
where where I am in my life with almost
one knows Allah yeah mashallah we've
come to an end thank you so much for
being with us here on the Deen show may
the crater to heavens the earth Allah
rewards you keep you steadfast and far
away from ever going back to that
lifestyle keep you and your family
blessed as he's blessed you with this
guidance it's such a gift you can have
the money you can have the fame but you
know that Islam submission to the will
of the creator not the creation is a
gift it's a priceless gift I mean the
crater keep you and keep me and keep all
of us
this Dean all the way to Jenna thank you
I said I'm a Laker boola thank you so
much brother Eddie for having me on the
show does it glow here
welcome Salaam we're a hostel a bracket
thank you so much once again peace be
with us Salaam alaikum
and that was sister Nina
she went from pop culture icon pop music
singing dancing and having that
celebrity status as a very famous
musician but something was missing and
as you can hear from her story she's
happy now she's very happy she's doing
the right thing and many people can
relate to this because many people not
the majority they want to be like the
stars they're reaching for the stars and
it doesn't matter what it takes
they're going through all sorts of
obstacles to get that Fame to try to get
that dollar and end up worshiping the
dollar worshiping the fame the fashion
but our life is not just about that it's
about a more important thing his life is
short and we're here for a short amount
of time so it's about really knowing the
purpose of life learning it living it
and dying upon it and you've been led
here to the Deen show today and I hope
you've gotten a benefit from this lady's
story and we pray that the crater
continues to guide her guide us and
keeps us steadfast continue to turn into
the Deen show you can follow us on our
Twitter and check us out on our Facebook
if you have any suggestions or some
topic that you'd like to see us cover
and some feedback and until next time
we'll see you until then God one peace
be with you